so this is crazy you'd think this is
happening in a third-world country but
no it's happening here in America
although we're on our way to becoming a
third world country they are gonna start
shutting off water to citizens of
Detroit because people are behind on
their payments because obviously we got
a major bad economic situation going on
in Detroit right now there is a hundred
eighteen million dollar debt in the
Detroit water and sewage department
that's what they have so every week
they're gonna shut off water supplies to
three thousand people - which will lead
to about a hundred fifty thousand people
in total we've got a little more info
for you so nearly half of the 320,000
residents who use the utility are
delinquent so they're just not paying
their bills anymore and Detroit's
average monthly water bill is nearly
double the national average of $40 and
the Detroit City Council approved a nine
percent hike last week so they're
they're increasing what the water costs
is the same time as they have this
tremendous amount of people that can't
afford it and we've got a quote from a
member of the the Coalition in charge of
this operation we are asking the UN
Special Rapporteur to make clear to the
US government that it has violated the
human right to water if the US
government does not respond
appropriately this will also impact
their Universal Periodic Review when
they stand before the Human Rights
Council to have their human rights
record evaluated that's more Barlow
she's the national chairperson of the
Council of Canadians obviously Detroit
Canada they're close to each other so
this is a board that's dealing with some
of these issues and they want the UN to
come in and help Americans get water so
I guess the most basic thing here is we
need to just give these people free
water right like we got to suck it up
and let our own citizens have water what
is going on that we're at a point where
we are questioning whether or not to
keep people water withholding that yeah
I mean it's Canadian water - you saw
that council Canadians it's Niagara
water there's a lot of it
there's plenty right there's okay so
somebody was watching this and I'm sure
somebody's watching this and going well
you know what if these people can't
afford their water then they don't
deserve their orders so what would you
say to those people I would like those
people to go a few days without water
and let me know
how it works out for them I mean this is
not something that is you know some
something people can't have like oh this
is cable TV they're not paying their
cable bill we're gonna cut off their
cable this is something that they need
to survive this is a human rights issue
there are people who are on life-support
in homes connected to machines and it is
illegal to cut off their electricity
because they need that to survive people
need water to survive and what is the
alternative they're gonna get sick
they're gonna get dehydrated then
they're gonna go to the hospitals we
have to pay for that well where are they
gonna flush the toilets I mean if
sanitation was gonna throw at the
streets like we used to
right I mean then there's gonna be
diseases and this is gonna be a problem
that affects everyone how is it even
logical to want to take that road it's
gonna cost more money the government not
doing something logical I can't believe
but right so you're onto something there
because if you do shut off the water to
these people the amount of disease
that's gonna increase I mean it's a
short-term financial answer to what will
then lead to a much bigger
socio-economic and health problem and
all that yeah what do we do it's I I
mean I think for right now I think we
have to this is one of those issues that
really has to be taken and taken one day
one week one month at a time because
we're talking about something that's so
vital to human survival yeah and right
now listen Detroit you can't get your
[ __ ] together you can't afford water get
Obama to pay for it get the government I
pay taxes I'm happy to contribute to
keep my fellow brethren alive and while
I grad you can pay for my water bill too
because it is expensive yeah and I can
if you or I have a low-wage job 80 bucks
a month is a lot of money you know I can
afford it thankfully however I can
understand that it is a struggle because
believe it or not I was once there where
I was from gig to gig to gig and your
bills it's it's hard to keep that all in
check at the end of every month yeah I
mean as a comic I know it being behind
on yeah yeah how important you guys
think it is that we keep Detroit going
because remember during the election
they kept saying Biden kept saying bin
Laden is dead
and GM is alive you know implying that
Detroit is alive but now we keep hearing
about all this bad uh maybe they want I
don't think they'd want it actually but
but how important is it that we keep
this Detroit going because it's sort of
it seems to me that it's like the Ground
Zero of what could really start
spreading across the country if we shut
off water to Detroit or we don't help it
come back economically and all that
that's a slippery slope man I'm all for
leave no man behind because then what we
are we going to annex New Orleans or
we're gonna add it are we gonna start
just picking territories that we don't
like and get rid getting rid of them
it's it's that you know we are Americans
take them in I think you reverse oh my
god see that would be like this is why
you host the show and I anacs would be
if we want we welcome them in yeah we're
not doing that no we're definitely not
it took Detroit they'd be anything we
should convince Fannin will be anything
to send yeah where's the pride that
comes along with like people part of our
country I mean that is part of our
country those are Americans yeah how
could we consider taking their waterway
and why is that the first thing that
pops into people's minds they can't pay
their bills so we should take away their
water like maybe the idea of creating
jobs or thinking of something that would
economically help the area grow like
that's not something that people
immediately think of the first thought
that most people commented on this was
then cut it off if they can't pay it
they can't expect me to pay it on their
neighbor and it's just like really yeah
look at such a socialist wanting water
for everybody by the way what percentage
what percentage of our bodies is water
80 or something percentage of your body
is water so let's just give water to
people that can't afford it we can't do
that much right but I'm pretty sure we
could try it's roughly 80 it's right
around yeah yeah drink water we're all
in the same boat it's good for you